et on le souligne depuis quelques jours
avec le docteur car le vice président de
l'association des médecins
microbiologiste-infectiologue du québec
dr weiss bonsoir alors oui c'est quand
on regarde le portrait en général les
nouvelles sont plutôt bonnes en tout cas
c'est sous contrôle pour l'instant
optimisme prudent
mais quand on regarde la situation dans
les 6 h et celle des dans les résidences
pour personnes âgées
là on se dit c'est éminemment triste est
ce qu'on aurait pu agir autrement et
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire à partir de
maintenant de mieux dr weiss quel est
votre avis là-dessus c'est clair qu'au
québec le problème
malheureusement les décès vient vc-1
chez celles des ce sont des
environnements qui sont difficilement
contrôlables parce que ce sont des
milieux de vie
quant à une propagation très rapide
virus ce sont malheureusement des gens
qui sont vulnérables puisque souvent des
personnes âgées avec des problèmes sous
jacents
donc c'est sûr que c'est de mettre
beaucoup de ressources actuellement dans
les ch et celle d essayer entre
guillemets de transformer l'essai h et
celle des entre guillemets en hôpitaux
de soins aigus mais là faut que je fasse
attention à la façon dont ça sorte ne
peut pas dire qu'on devrait avoir des
soins intensifs dans des séries chez
celle d'aimer ça veut dire qu'il faut
certainement augmenter le nombre de
personnel médical infirmière de deux
préposés et ses pouvoirs à les optimiser
les traitements à cesser ces
personnes-là impulse avait le fait
d'avoir demandé aux gens peut-être de
sortir leurs membres de deux familles et
leurs familles des ch et celle des ceux
qui peuvent le faire est d'essayer de
les retirer ceux qui sont encore en
santé ceux qui vont encore bien dans des
endroits où il n'ya pas d'éclosion etc
c'est faut pas oublier ce sont nos aînés
qui ont bâti le québec alors on leur
doit une fière chandelle
donc ces gens là ils ont le droit
d'avoir peut-être je dirais un support à
un moment de leur vie
et quand on dit on doit les tester
systématiquement testés c'est lui là on
va le faire à sainte dorothée on va le
faire ailleurs ça peut aider dans la
mesure où si quelqu'un pour effecter bon
ça arrange qu'ils ne le soient pas là on
dirait des limites en terme de nos tests
il ya beaucoup de problèmes sur l'aspect
d'obtenir des réactifs toute la
logistique des tests c'est pas qu'on est
pas capable de faire ces tests là mais
il ya toutes sortes de problèmes
techniques qui fait que nous sommes
limités dans la quantité est ce qu'on
peut faire actuellement
et ça ça rend les choses beaucoup plus
compliquées et beaucoup plus difficile
donc on ne peut pas tester à l'infini
comme on aimerait le faire alors parce
que c'est sûr qu'on aimerait tester de
tous les sièges à saldé voir qui serait
positif négatif asymptomatiques positif
essayez de corte des gens qui est toute
une stratégie à avoir dans ce genre de
contexte là il ya aussi les travailleurs
de la santé qui s'y rendent s'assurer
que ces gens là ne sont pas malades mais
a qu'un hier on avait un reportage là
dessus a qu'un des tests plus accès plus
rapide
c'est vrai c'est sa suite ça se fait pas
facilement je vous dirai à moins que
vous ayez une industrie locale qui soit
capable de produire de façon massive
mais est on est en compétition aussi
avec toutes sortes d'endroits sur la
planète
donc ça va prendre encore quelques
semaines voire quelques mois avant
d'avoir institué des tests vous dire est
facilement disponible un peu partout et
c'est donc ce site il faut pas qu'il
faut pas oublier qu'on a été pris de
court globalement à l'échelle planétaire
par ce virus là et c'est déjà bien qu'on
la déteste parce que nous avons quand
même penser comme en décembre
on savait pas qu'elle était la cause du
virus qu'on a rapidement identifié le
virus
on a fait des tests ça fait même pas six
mois on a on connaît le virus on sait
déjà testé dans sa vie juste pour vous
donner une idée en 1917 pendant la
grippe espagnole la rosa est un virus
qui à l'époque n'avait même pas encore
été isolé alors ça a été très vite mais
justement la première question du public
c'est exactement le thème abordé lors ce
qu'un vaccin sera trouvée vous
demande-t-on sera-t-il efficace à 100%
ont partiellement comme celui de la
grippe saisonnière avec les 100%
médecine ça n'existe pas c'est la
première chose qu'on apprend aux
étudiants en médecine ne zéro absolu et
le sens absolu n'existe pas donc ça va
être un vaccin qu'on espère qu'il
prêterait combien je le sais pas
l'idée c'est que c'est un vaccin qui va
être différente la grille de la grippe
c'est un ya plusieurs vies réussissent
en changeant ça varie d'une année à
l'autre
cette fois ci on n'a pas envie qu'on va
utiliser un type de celui ci le prix de
19 et donc on va viser un donc c'est
plus facile c'est un peu comme ont lâché
leur sein pour le h1n1 c'est un vaccin
très ciblé un vaccin qui ne te diriges
est que quand un type de virus sont
habituellement ils sont beaucoup plus
efficaces
très bien est-ce que les gens qui ont
perdu l'odorat on en a parlé ce matin
avec votre collègue docteur carignan
parce que ça c'est assez généralisé pas
généraliser mais ça se retrouve chez 60
% des gens ou à peu près là qui ont la
coved 19
est ce que le dorat revient cette
question peut-être naïve mais c'est une
très bonne question ça revient après la
notamment il faut aussi souligner que
c'est quelque chose de très très
particulier il ya à peu près aucun
risque connus qui donne ce genre de
choses là de façon aussi fréquenté aussi
spécifique
donc c'est vraiment c'est pas de
pratiquement un signe d'infection par le
commis 19
donc si c'est quelque chose de très bien
connu pour ce virus là est-ce que ça
revient oui ça revient mais ça peut
revenir avec tous les degrés toutes les
teintes de gris de partiellement ou
totalement
alors la majorité du temps ça va revenir
mais ça se peut qu'ils aient des gens
qui restent avec certaines séquelles
même qu'il soit bon une dernière
question le disais c'est la fin de
semaine de pâques
est ce que c'est vrai que le virus se
propage facilement avec des fleurs
coupées
impossible pour nous de cheminées des
fleurs pour pâques à notre maman qui
habite une maison de retraite
je sais pas si ça sur mine avec des
sueurs mais ça peut être une surface
inanimé c'est pas la fleur va être le
problème c'est des personnes qui vont
amener les fleurs alors c'est sûr que si
quelqu'un est contaminée et transporte
un vase des fleurs les pauses et c'est
tout il ne venait la contamination
plutôt classe leur en question mais
peut-être le message à passer et je
pense qu'il faut réitérer à tout le
monde sait que les fêtes de pâques s'en
viennent et s'il vous plaît restez chez
vous voilà on reste chez nous qu'on
envoie des fleurs virtuelles ou des
dessins dr weiss
c'est beaucoup encore une fois d'avoir
été insulté
merci beaucoup